so yeah I noticed blood on on my other
dog and I'm like what the hell's going
on and so I started calling and calling
and then slowly that sinking feeling and
I realized my little chihuahua
a freaking owl came down and took took
down about an owl man I thought you were
gonna say coyote for sure here's here's
this animal that's entrusted its life to
you you're you're its protector my
little dog was just slowly stripped a
lot it's just like horrific yeah that's
awful and
people often get mad at me because that
night it was a bit chilly out and I'd
wrap them in bacon
no I do no owls love owls love bacon no
no I'm trying the only way I could get
through it is to joke about it that's
what this show is all about